dans ces box finalement c'est des dons
ou des rideaux que je récupère moi
et j'avais envie de vous proposer
quelque chose avec ce rideau elle n'a
pas de baguette magique mais une machine
à coudre Mélissa s'est bien est une
créatrice de mode elle fabrique des
vêtements à partir de récupération de
tissus ce jour-là elle va transformer un
rideau en jupe la matière et quand j'ai
besoin d'un patron je mets un patron
c'est lui qui va me permettre de
découper un vêtement à la bonne taille à
la bonne forme voilà c'est vraiment
l'essence même en fait du vêtement la
naissance du vêtement pour cette
création pas besoin de patron là du coup
comme c'est une jupe d'hiver je vais
ajouter une doublure aussi pour
renforcer le pour ajouter un peu plus de
chaleur en fait et que finalement on
n'est pas froid en portant le vêtement
là du coup je vais passer à la partie
couture donc à la réalisation des
ourlets l'assemblage de la doublure avec
la le tissu principal et la mise en
place d'un élastique
[Musique]
en 45 minutes la jupe est terminée
autodidacte dans sa pratique la
couturière a appris toute seule elle a
développé sa propre méthode et
correspondable c'est vraiment la matière
qui va m'inspirer un vêtement donc
parfois ça va être spontané parfois il
va s'écouler plusieurs mois il y a
beaucoup de récupération parce que
finalement toutes mes chutes de tissus
sont transformées en accessoires de mode
chouchou petit sac petite pochette pour
vraiment être sur du zéro déchet
j'achète aussi des tissus qui viennent
de stock dormant donc ça veut dire que
ce sont des tissus que qui sont
entreposés dans des entrepôts et qui ont
une vocation à finir brûler ou incinérer
à Richebourg près de Houdan Mélissa
ouvert son magasin en mars 2022
l'artisan a commencé son activité en
2018 elle était encore salariée mais
libinoise kit son emploi en mars 2020
pour se consacrer pleinement à son
activité entrepreneuriale je trouvais
que la mode
l'artisanat en fait dans la mode était
en train de complètement disparaître on
en entend plus parler au profit
justement de ces gros industriels qui
produisent en surproduction dans les
usines donc plus d'originalité beaucoup
de problèmes aussi de taille mal coupées
vêtements qui tourne au lavage bref la
qualité qui commence à devenir un petit
peu compliqué chemisier manteau jupe les
vêtements sont divers la créatrice vient
même de lancer une collection pour bébé
à la mode de Mélissa